Colin and I are going to visually act
out a function that adds two numbers
together the script calls the function
with the following line y equals x add
parentheses X comma Y the script needs
to get these values of X&Y and give
those to the function my ad notice the
script is not handing the variables x
and y to my ad it just passes the values
that were stored in X and Y my ad now
does something with those numbers the
script has no idea what the function is
actually doing with the number when the
function is done it can return values in
this case the function returns a single
number and the script stores the number
that the function return in the variable
Y and now we're done
now let's go through this again in
greater detail the script is going to
hand two values to the function my ad
let's peek in on what the function is
actually doing the function is declared
with the line function x equals my add
parentheses X comma Z my ad is the name
of the function it takes two inputs
which is stores in X and Z my ID gives
one output the script will take the
output in store its value and why even
though the function has a variable
called X it is not the same axes in the
script we say these two x's have
different scopes the functions X and the
script X can have different values the
script cannot change the value of x and
the function it can only pass a value to
the function and the function will
decide what to do with it my ad now
stores the second value in Z the
function takes these two values adds
them together and stores and back in the
variable X notice that the variable X
inside the function has a different
value than the variable X outside the
function this is possible because the
two variables are not of the same scope
now there are no more lines of code in
the function it returns a value three in
this case to the script that called it
the script stores this value and why
in theory the my ad function
any two inputs in this case the stripped
is passing the letter Q and the number
three when the function tries to add the
values together it will return the
number but it doesn't necessarily make
sense
because of this it's a good idea to have
your function check to see what the
inputs are and make sure that they are
what you want if not the functions are
returned an error